more examples of wil education infecting
America's classrooms the Pittsburgh
Public School Board shelling out
$50,000 to a Consulting Group that aims
to dismantle racism in math class the
group will educate teachers on how to
replace white supremacy culture
practices in math instruction with
methods that Center on the wellness of
students of color but parents are sick
of all the wokeness creeping up in the
classroom and it could explain why
there's been a ma a major boom in
homeschooling in America The Washington
Post noticing noting that this has
increased by over 50% since 2018 and is
now the fastest growing form of
education so Dana this makes sense to me
then they're inserting agendas into M
you watch and are a participant on the
five I had an idea today Greg oh ex that
there should be an AI assignment editor
for the media and then they could save
some everybody could save some money and
all you have to do is have the AI robot
watch the five and then in two to three
years you will write a story that says
wow isn't this interesting there's more
homeschooling who would have ever
guessed yeah you are we are the
assignment editor for America but we're
just like two or three years ahead of
everybody that's where this was going
Glenn yunan he became governor of
Virginia by getting Standing Ovation
saying I am going to make sure that
advanced math and reading is taught in
all of your schools I just found this
out though huge news in Virginia that
one school had eight fental overdoses in
3 weeks and nobody told the parents
anything geez l so now the governor has
said well we're going to have to do that
too so I think parents are hyper
involved and they're saying where else
what else can we do and if a
homeschooling option is available and
there's lots more tools now it's much
more popular I'm not saying it's the
easiest thing and I I know that there's
a lot of complications but if you are in
a situation where you're it's unsafe for
your kids to go to school or you're not
trusting what they're going to get and
you think that you can do it better of
course parents are going to make that
choice Harold what do you think about
these school districts spending all this
money on these big contracts while they
distract from just
math so I'm a a firm believer that 2
plus 2 is four and four time 8 is 32
there's no woke or Black Or Hispanic or
white way to teach that we should teach
kids the basics I love competition and
education it gives parents more Choice
more choices homeschooling is a choice
and if a parent is able to do that uh
they should have every right to do it
and the school system should be
supportive and provide the resources for
it the group group of people who get
talked about every election at every
level local state and federal or kids
they get talked about uh about how we
want to improve their education they
have no vote we have failed them
consistently for the last 70 years
there's some schools don't get me wrong
there are a lot of teachers we sometimes
bash teachers and think a little bit too
much uh but students people 18 and under
get short changed every election cycle
because we don't improve their their
schools and when anyone comes to
introduce competition and give more more
choice you have a bunch of adults who
fight and squabble over it when the kids
are really the ones that would be the
beneficiaries if we allow more choice
and more competition so I applaud any
competition that produces more Choice
which produces better results and if
this is a better result homeschooling is
a better result for these kids give it
to them if a voucher is a better result
give it to them if public education is
the right thing in the community let
that be the case this the students need
to win and the only way they win is that
the parents have more choices Greg you
like this idea I certainly do well said
Harold Ford Jr I think right now you're
seeing the educational equivalent of the
law and hoarder pincher move that I
mentioned in the B Block Brian I
remember like yesterday yes on the one
hand you have a toxic public education
system that contaminates brains while
you prevent escape from that system by
stamping out school choice wherever
possible wherever it arises you hear the
left like try to destroy it meanwhile
who's exempt from this pincher move the
politicians and administrations who send
their little brats to private you know
it's great to be the ward and son
because your son's not in prison we need
to introduce a law and I don't know how
you do it but it's got maybe it's an
executive order when I'm president in
2028 deny If you deny choice to others
your choice will be denied as well so if
you are against school choice your kids
have to go to public it's like the the
anti-choice leader is like the is no
different than a proar hawk who makes
sure his kids never fight or a hardcore
prolifer who uses abortion his birthday
control which doesn't exist but it's the
same it's the same uh action Ryan I'm
going to I'm going to build on my
optimistic tone from a couple of blocks
ago and say one of the good things about
a terrible situation with the pandemic
is everyone became aware of this looking
over the shoulder of their kids say what
are you learning what are you doing what
what is going on here and now everyone
is zoned in on what's happening in their
schools and they care so something good
happened and I think people are going to
change what also I think is minorities
are also one from 3.3% of those
homeschooled up to 16 % so the parents
are engaged that's not good enough for
my kid I want them to raise I want to
raise the stakes homeschooling is Big
it's a big responsibility for the family
I will never put down teachers I think
they're underpaid and underappreciated
you can give them the Summers off they
need it I have no problem with that but
I but I will say this the best thing to
happen to with public school would be
competition because if all of a sudden
those vouchers could go to the school
down the block or the charter school
around the block all of a sudden I'm
going to why are we not having people
I'm going to have to lay off teachers if
we don't get better and respond to the
public we're going to lose teachers and
superintendent and we'll respond that
way and I I just think competition works
and I think that Greg saying to myself I
wish I said that are you saying that to
you I was I was also thinking how much
better Fox and Friends would be if there
was a competition
right we I know we need more people on
Fox EV okay all right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else